hey it's me again we're going to answer
the question do we really need fat in
our diet okay mainly we want to talk
about the essential fatty acids
essential meaning must come from diet
your body cannot make it it's required
by the body and there are basically two
categories of essential fatty acids we
have one category which is omega-6 fatty
acids which are generally inflammatory
and then you have the omega-3 fatty
acids which are anti-inflammatory and
you need a ratio of one to one most
people have a ratio to like one to ten
omega-6 or heavy on the omega-6 or one
to 25 very heavy on the omega-6 that's
why they're so inflamed and they've
arthritis and they have heart issues I
was at the fair this last weekend in
Pennsylvania I've never I've seen so
many deep-fried places where you could
buy deep-fried anything they deep-fry
cheesecake and Oreos and vegetables and
everything of course they kill
everything and of course I had to look
behind the curtain to see what kind of
oil they're using in its vegetable oil
which is actually soy oil
okay so let's GMO soy heavy omega-6 or
they might use corn oil which is also
GMO
so I think the biggest confusion that
people have with is with the chemistry
name linoleic versus alpha linolenic
acid okay this is linoleic versus alpha
little lennick linoleic is the vegetable
oil the corn the soil of safflower oil
sunflower oil cottonseed oil but it also
has other types of a category which is
called the GLA
which I'm not going to try to keep this
as simple as possible but it's hard GLA
types fats which are anti-inflammatory
so they're different than this but if
you're consuming like an omega-6 borage
oil evening primrose oil black currant
seed oil those are anti-inflammatory
those have a lot of health benefits and
they're very different than these oils I
mean it's okay to consume some safflower
oil but the problem is like don't
consume so much what you don't have
enough omega-3 so this is what we need
to focus on how
more of omega-3 fatty acids fish oils
it's not like the cod liver oil virgin
olive oil is the best if you could find
some it's a bit pricey or just fattier
fish sardines are really healthy walnuts
nuts are high in omega-3 flax is pretty
darn high in omega-3 seed other seeds
are real high in omega-3 Chia has the
most omega-3 of all the seeds then we
got hemp seed canola and so I have
around between 8 and 10 percent so
there's a little bit of omega-3 but
because it's GMO we're not going to
recommend it ok so you also have other
things that are essential in the body
called fat fybel vitamins so we don't
just have essential fatty acids we have
actual vitamins that are essential that
you need and you can't live without
and that would be vitamin A comes from
the fat vitamin D e k2 so those are
essential and it's also k1 as well so a
deficiency of essential fatty acid would
leave you with scaly dry skin dermatitis
all sorts of skin issues alopecia where
your hair is falling out low immune
system a lot of autoimmune cases are low
in essential fatty acids so it worse is
your memory your cognitive function
suffers it worsens your overall mood you
can become depressed it affects the
cardiovascular system and there's one
more point about this alpha linolenic
acid which is a type of omega 3 fatty
acid we need this raw material to be
able to enhance the most abundant fat in
your nervous system in your brain and
your retina of the eye to prevent
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's and to
prevent loss of vision and that is to
have this turn into something called DHA
okay now you can get DHA directly from
fish oils and egg yolks and other fatty
foods but if you're trying to get them
from vegetable sources and you have
insulin resistance
you're not going to convert those into
the actual fats that you need so you
might have a problem
so they answer your question do we
really need fat in our diets well the
answer is absolutely but we want to make
sure we have a ratio of
one two one oh my go three two omega-6
thanks for watching hi guys hey listen I
created a pretty amazing evaluation quiz
down below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root
cause of all of your symptoms the most
likely cause
so take the quiz now and we'll send you
a report